Yeah.
>> Go to Galatians 2.
>> Galatians 2
>> 11- 16.
>> Now when Peter had come to Antioch, I
withtood him to his face because he was
to be blamed.
>> He did what?
>> To be blamed.
>> Paul withtood an apostle of Jesus who
met Jesus and walked with Jesus
>> and he rebuked him and opposed him face
to face in front of the public.
>> And he wrote about it.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. and even wrote about it.
>> Yeah.
>> He wrote it in a letter that's being
read by millions for centuries inspired
by the spirit. Huh?
>> Yeah.
>> You see that?
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Read it one more time, sister. Because
people don't like these parts of the
Bible. This [laughter] part I don't like
either.
>> I don't like the rebuke because I'm
arrogant. May God destroy my pride and
arrogance and have mercy on all of us.
Read one more time.
Now when Peter had come to Antioch, I
withtood him to his face because he was
to be blamed. For before certain men
came from James, he would eat with the
Gentiles. But when they came, he
withdrew and separated himself, fearing
those who were of the circumcision.
>> Let me explain the context so you guys
know. You're getting a lot of meat
today. Even though it's not going to top
it, you're getting a lot of meat today.
Now, let me explain what Paul is saying.
There were Jews in Jerusalem who though
believed in Jesus thought Gentiles had
to get circumcised and keep the dietary
laws of Moses. If you didn't, they
considered you to be unsaved. So Paul
and Barnabas were in opposition with
this group.
>> They told these Jews, "No, Gentiles
don't have to be Jews. They don't have
to live like us. They don't have to eat
like us. They don't have to get
circumcised." Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And there was a sharp dispute. So much
so that Acts 15 tells us they actually
had to have a council and be in a
council in Jerusalem.
>> Yeah.
>> And Peter, James
>> and the other apostles and elders agree
with Paul and Barnabas over against
these Jews, saying, "No, they're right.
>> They're right. Gentiles don't have to be
Jews and act like Jews and dress like
Jews and eat like Jews. They don't need
to do that. If you're an ethnic Jew, you
do this. But if you're not, you don't
need to. Now, Peter, when he was in
Antioch, Syria, would sit with Gentiles
and eat. He wouldn't eat what they ate,
but he ate with them. Meaning, okay, you
eat sausage pizza. I don't eat sausage
pizza, so I'm going to have
>> pizza with mushroom.
>> Right?
>> So, Peter would sit and eat with them
until the Jews from Jerusalem came.
Peter out of fear of these Jews pulled
away and stopped eating with the
Gentiles,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> You understand why this is sin?
>> Because not only is Peter acting like a
hypocrite. Why? Because when these Jews
weren't here, you sat with the Gentiles.
You didn't distinguish Jews from
Gentiles. Made no distinction. You ate
with them, pray with them. Now you turn
your back on them because these Jews,
you don't want them to be offended,
thereby hurting these Gentiles and
confusing them.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's the context, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So now pick it up.
>> And the rest of the Jews also played the
hypocrites with him. So that's even
Barnabas played the hypocrite.
>> Yeah.
>> With him.
>> Oh, no. I don't think you get it when he
says, "And the other Jews at Antioch
also played the hypocrite." He just
called Peter a hypocrite.
>> Yeah.
>> Paul is calling Peter a hypocrite for
all to read publicly.
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> Oh, but people tell you, "Brother, it's
not right when you rebuke someone
publicly, that's not being Christlike."
Really? So you mean Paul when he rebuked
Peter and the other Jews as hypocrites
in front of the Gentiles and then writes
about it where millions have read that
letter for 2,000 years millions have
read Paul inspired by the spirit to say
Peter was a hypocrite and I rebuked him.
>> He wasn't being Christlike.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He was
>> he wasn't being Christlike.
Let me explain the difference between
Matthew 18. We don't need to turn there.
I'll just tell you what it says because
people misquote this. In Matthew 18:15-1
17, Jesus says, "If your brother sins
against you, go and show him his fault
alone."
>> Right
>> there. Jesus is talking about a sin
against you. Not a sin against God in
front of others to see.
>> Oh,
>> it's talking about a personal offense
between you and another party, not a sin
against God that everyone is privy to
and seeing and observing. If you sin
publicly, you must be rebuked publicly
for the benefit of others.
>> Yeah.
>> But if it's a private sin between you
and someone, keep it private. Confront
the person and if they don't repent then
you bring other witnesses then you go to
the church.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Wow. Clear. Yeah. So clear.
>> So was Peter sin a private sin against
Paul or was it a public sin in few full
view of the church where publicly he was
eating with Gentiles and publicly he
pulled away for everyone to see?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's right.
>> That's why Paul had to rebuke and shame
him publicly.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Yeah.
>> You see?
>> The Bible is beautiful. The
[clears throat] Bible's supernatural if
it's properly interpreted, understood.
There are no real contradictions.
>> Amen. Hallelujah. Thank you, brother.
This is so good.
>> But now watch what he goes on to say.
And this is all about Paul. You see why
Paul is a hero. He's my hero. May I be
like Paul in Jesus name. I'm far
>> may we all be like Paul in Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> Our heroes
reading where you stop.
>> Okay. And the rest of the Jews also
played the hypocrite with him. So that's
even Barnabas was carried away with
their hypocrisy.
>> Even my partner in ministry fell for
Peter's hypocrisy and went alongside
with him and agreed with him and pulling
away from the Gentiles. In other words,
Paul was now left alone to oppose Peter,
the other Jews, and his own min ministry
partner Barnabas. And he has no
hesitation to rebuke all of them because
he didn't care about what people
thought. He cared about the glory of
Jesus.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Praise God.
>> You see my point?
>> So clear. Yes.
>> Okay. What's before you You're not done
yet. My point is, if I have to offend
all of you because you've done something
to dishonor the Lord, making you hate
me, so be it. May I never prostitute
myself for fame or money. May I be
zealous for the glory of Jesus. I love
him more than you. Meaning, I love you
more than I love you. So, if I have to
rebuke, you don't like it. Tough luck.
I'm going to answer to Jesus, not to
you.
>> Yeah.
>> We love that.
>> Okay.
>> We all need that. We all need that.
Yeah. Thank you. We need to stop being
crowdleasers. Yeah.
>> Wishywashy effeminists who think that
this is Christianity and being pious and
humble. This is why the church is in the
mess that's that it's in in the West
because we got a bunch of sissies
thinking they're doing Jesus a favor.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. True.
>> This is not biblical Christianity. It's
not. It's not the Christianity of Paul
and Peter and of our Lord Jesus and of
the prophets.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [snorts] Yeah.
>> Okay. Now finish it, sister.
>> Yeah.
>> But when I saw that they were not
straightforward about the truth of the
gospel, I said to Peter before them all,
"If you being a Jew live in the manner
of Gentiles and not as the Jews, why do
you compel Gentiles to live as Jews?"
>> You understand what he's saying? This is
a lot of meat.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> They left me no choice but to rebuke
them publicly. I had to shame Peter
public. You know why?
>> Yeah.
>> If Peter was not rebuked publicly and
publicly disassociating from the
Gentiles, then he would have misled the
Gentiles into thinking, you know what,
we're wrong. We're in sin. These Jews
are right. We need to act like Jews, eat
like Jews, and dress like Jews or we're
not saved. Because Peter did this
publicly. So I'm a Gentile. Peter pulls
away from me. Peter, why? Oh, because we
Jews can't sit with you Gentiles.
Because you're eating stuff forbidden.
Oh, wow. Peter,
>> then that means I'm not really pleasing
to the Lord and I'm not honoring the
Lord. Now I have to be like you and act
like you.
>> And Paul had to then correct that
publicly. Peter, shame on you.
When these Jews weren't here, you used
to sit with these Gentiles and act like
them. Now that they came, you pulled
away and now demand that these Gentiles
act like you Jews. WHAT A HYPOCRITE.
What about the time when you eat with
them? Why did you change, Peter? See,
he's rebuking them to correct them so
others don't fall for the hypocrisy.
>> Yeah.
>> Got it.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Thank you so much. Paul Paul loved Jesus
and his church to not allow even a
pillar of the church, even a disciple of
Jesus appointed by Jesus to mislead
people by his hypocrisy.
>> Yeah. And this also teaches us a perfect
gives us a perfect example. Even the
best of saints, the most spiritfilled
human ambassadors of Christ are capable
of committing the worst sins. Which is
why we should not focus on any man but
on Jesus because even Peter will
disappoint you but Jesus cannot
disappoint you.
>> Right.
>> Amen.
>> And that's what Paul is showing you.
Paul is saying don't look to me. Don't
make me more than I am. Don't look to
Peter. We will disappoint you. We are
sinners. We act inconsistently. We are
prone to sinning. Look to Jesus who can
never shame or disappoint you.
Never make us more than we are. Never.
>> We will disappoint you. Right.
[clears throat]
>> Uh finish. Where do you want me to go
till? Sorry.
>> Oh, it was till 16. Sorry. I thought it
was till 14. Okay. We who are Jews by
nature and not sinners of the Gentiles,
know that a man is not justified by the
works of the law, but by faith in Jesus
Christ. Even we have believed in Christ
Jesus that we might be justified by
faith in Christ and not by the works of
the law. For by the works of the law, no
flesh shall be justified.
>> You see what he means here? He's being
sarcastic when he says, "We who are Jews
are not sinners like the Gentiles."
Sinners, not saying they're sinners and
we're not. He's mocking them using their
language like, "Yeah, those sinners were
not like those sinners."
>> Yeah.
>> He's mocking the Jews because the Jews
look to the Gentiles as sinners because
of their customs and the way they ate.
>> So saying even we Jews who are special,
unlike those sinners, Gentiles, we're
both saved the same way. So why are you
making them live like Jews, act like
Jews, speak like Jews, dress like Jews,
and eat like Jews? What's the matter
with you?
>> You understand?
>> This chapter destroys this cult called
Hebrew Roots Movement where Gentiles
start acting like Jews, dressing like
Jews, eating like Jews, and even
[clears throat] changing their names to
Jewish names, thinking that Gentiles
need to be Jewish to be more special and
favored by God. Paul already condemned
that in Galatians 2.
>> Yeah.
>> You see it?
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Galatians 3:28. What does he say?
Galatians 3:28.
>> 3:28.
>> 28.
It says, "There is neither Jew nor
Greek. There is neither slave nor free.
There is neither male nor female. For
you are all one in Christ Jesus."
>> I love this. the Hebrew roots. Hebrew
roots cult.
>> Yeah.
>> God doesn't care about your ethnicity.
To him, there is no Jew or Gentile.
>> He doesn't care about your gender in the
sense that he doesn't think males are
better than females. If you belong to
Jesus, you're all one in Jesus. And God
loves you equally for who you are. If
you're a Gentile, that's a female. He
loves you just as much as that Jewish
male.
>> Yeah.
Yet the Hebrew roots movement
gives the impression that I'm cursed
because I'm a Gentile who speaks in a
language other than Hebrew. So now I
have to be a Jew who speaks Hebrew and
act like a Jew for God to love me even
more. Blasphemy.
>> Yeah, it is blasphemy. Yeah. Thank you.
>> Okay. Blasphemy. Now, what was the point
of quoting Galatians 2?
Paul rebuked, shamed
Peter and the other Jews and Barnabas
publicly when they sinned against the
Lord and when they looked down upon and
discriminated against the Gentiles. And
he even mentioned it in a letter read
publicly by Christians at the time. And
over 2,000 years, millions of Christians
have read Paul rebuking Peter publicly.
and he was inspired to mention it. And
you think you're more spiritual, more
humble, more pious than Paul.
>> And then you sit in judgment of people
who rebuke Christians publicly for
sinning publicly, shaming the Lord
publicly, disgracing the Lord publicly.
>> Who the heck do you think you are?
>> True.
>> And the most important lesson to learn
from this, the most important lesson,
>> Yeah. Peter, who is an apostle of our
Lord, the rock that Jesus built his
church upon in union with the other
apostles, as great as he was, he's still
a human sinner who made mistakes. Shame
the Lord even after he was born of the
spirit. Because the Lord is showing you,
as great as these men were, don't look
to them. Don't put your trust in them.
They will disappoint you badly. Look to
Jesus who can never disappoint you. This
is why people want to attack let's say
bishops or the pope. Look how evil
corrupt they are. And just because the
pope is corrupt doesn't mean that office
is not of God. That church doesn't
belong to God anymore than Peter being a
hypocrite shaming the Lord means he
wasn't a true apostle or that office
wasn't ordained by God. Right.